في الوقت الحالي ، يعد الضغط من أجل
وقف إطلاق النار الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني
عالميًا إلى حد
ما ، حيث أجرت الأمم المتحدة نقاشًا حول هذه
القضية حتى أن الدبلوماسيين قد نزلوا
فعليًا إلى المنطقة
بينما نتحدث أن رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو يجتمع مع
أعضاء حكومته
الأمنية  ناقشوا الوضع ، هذه
صور من
اليوم وأيضًا أصدر الديوان الملكي الأردني اليوم
بيانًا قال فيه
إن نائب الرئيس الأمريكي كامالا هاريس اتصل
بالملك عبد الله لمناقشة التوترات
معي الآن شخص مر
بهذه العملية مرات عديدة قبل أن يكون ناصر
جودة أجنبيًا أردنيًا سابقًا.
وزير
ونائب رئيس الوزراء حالياً
عضو مجلس شيوخ أردني يشكر ناصر
جودي على تواجده معنا.
ما الذي تسمعه عن
اتفاق وقف إطلاق نار محتمل
بين حماس وإسرائيل تفيد الصحافة الإسرائيلية
بأن
أه الإسرائيليين أبلغوا
المصريين بأن شيئاً ما تم الاتفاق عليه
هو أنتم.  أسمع أي
شيء أسمع ما تسمعه أم
أه نحن جميعًا  دعت إلى وقف
الأعمال العدائية من أجل وقف إطلاق النار
ولكني أه أصلي مثل الملايين
حول العالم وخاصة في هذه
المنطقة أن هذا لن يكون مجرد
وقف آخر لإطلاق النار مع إفلات إسرائيل
مما فعلته.
الصحفي والمراسل المخضرم
الذي غطى هذه المنطقة لعقود
قال كل شيء بالكلمات والصور ،
آمل أن تتم معالجة الأسباب الجذرية
بدلاً من إسرائيل والهروب
ووصفها بأنها التفاف
وقول إن عملنا يتم هنا
وعندما نقوم  المضي قدمًا والأمل في
التخلص منه مرة أخرى
، يجب معالجة الأسباب الجذرية ولكن
لا يبدو أنه
يتم التعامل مع تلك الأسباب ، يبدو أنه من
المحتمل
أن يؤدي هذا ببساطة إلى وقف الأعمال
العدائية وليس معالجة بعض  تلك
القضايا المهمة جدًا التي تؤدي
مرارًا وتكرارًا إلى دورة عنف وعنيفة
تتجدد
مرارًا وتكرارًا كل بضع سنوات
وهذا هو بالضبط وجهة نظري أم أه أم
رأينا أه
غزة 2008 2009  غزة 2012
غزة 2014 وفي ما بين المناوشات والغارات
وأم وما إلى ذلك فأنا أتمنى
ألا يكون هذا من هؤلاء
أه أن تستمر أم أه هذا
فيلم رعب شاهدناه جميعًا من
قبل
أه أربع مرات خلال فترة ولايتي
كوزير للخارجية ، لذلك آمل
ألا يكون هذا من بين ما يجب أن يستمر
أو فيلم رعب مع
أه مع تكملة أخرى قادمة في
المستقبل ، يجب معالجة الأسباب الجذرية
عندما أعني
ما أعنيه بالأسباب الجذرية
نهاية الاحتلال ، نهاية
القهر ، نهاية ما هو أساسًا فصل عنصري ،
هذا غير مقبول في عالم اليوم ،
خذنا وراء الكواليس ، لقد كنت
جزءًا من هذه العملية قبل أن أعني
ما إذا كانت حماس وإسرائيل تبلغ
المصريين بأنهم  لقد توصلوا إلى نوع
من الاتفاق
حول كيفية توصيلهم لكيفية
عمل هذا بالضبط لأنه لا يوجد
حديث مباشر بين الاثنين
جيدًا ، فقد كان المبعوثون
المصريون أثناء التنقل وكانت
هناك قنوات
ولكن هانا أقصد اسمحوا لي أن أتحدث  هل ترجع
لو جاز لي
بغض النظر عن طريقة عمل
قنوات الاتصال أه
وبغض النظر عن نتيجة هذه
المحادثات ونأمل أن
تنتهي الغارات الجوية
والقصف والعنف
والموت والدمار
الذي رأيناه  في تقرير بن ويدمان ،
أعني أنني لست بحاجة إلى إعادة النظر في التفاصيل
مرة أخرى ، لقد
قال الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
اليوم إنه يشعر بالرعب
من مقتل 10 أفراد من نفس العائلة
في غارة جوية واحدة
تم قصف مدارس
تم قصف المستشفيات
والعيادات تم قصفها لذلك هذا
يجب أن يتوقف
عليك معالجة الأسباب
الجذرية لذلك والسبب الجذري لهذه
المشكلة برمتها هو الاحتلال
وضرورة العودة
إلى طاولة المفاوضات حيث تقوم
دولة فلسطينية مستقلة  اممم
وسلم وأمن لكل
شعوب أه المنطقة مرة
أخرى بالطبع لكن هذا أنا أفهم
وجهة نظرك هنا لكن
كل هذا بدأ قبل أن يبدأ حماس
بإطلاق الصخور.  بدأ
باقتحام المسجد الأقصى
بدأ
بجرأة شديدة بحسب الكثير أه
ردة فعل
على أه احتجاجا على الإخلاء القسري
في القدس الشرقية
ثم حماس بالطبع
استغلت الوضع برمته
بشكل انتهازي وبدأت بإطلاق صواريخ حماس.
إلحاق ضرر هائل بشعبها ،
أليس كذلك لأن العالم لم يكن
يركز على غزة على الإطلاق
حتى بدأت حماس في إطلاق الصواريخ
كان الناس في الواقع ينتبهون
لبعض هذه القضايا التي تطرحها
جيدًا أم هانا يمكننا أه  نحن في كل مرة
يحدث
فيها تصعيد أو اندلاع في هذا الجزء
من العالم ندخل في
الأعراض بدلاً من
الأسباب وندخل في استقطاب
السرد وسننهي هذا
نأمل التصعيد وننهي الموت وندمر
الدمار
وبعد ذلك سنعود إلى
لوحة الرسم ولا يجب أن نعود إلى
لوحة الرسم علينا أن نعود إلى
مفاوضات جادة.
هل صحيح أم ما بدأ
هذا ليس إطلاق صواريخ على
إسرائيل
ما بدأ هذا في الواقع حتى
قبل عاصفة المسجد الأقصى
ما بدأ هذا كان مضايقة
المصلين المسيحيين أه في خلال
الأسبوع المقدس من يوم الأحد إلى يوم الأحد.
اقتحام الأقصى ، أعتقد أنه
إذا كان بإمكاني القفز فقط ، أنا آسف ، أنا
آسف للمقاطعة إذا كان بإمكاني القفز فقط في
حماس هو اختطاف ما كان
نقاشًا جوهريًا حول الحقوق الفلسطينية ،
لذلك هناك الكثير من اللوم على  اذهب
هنا ، هل تقبل أن
لا أقبل بأنني أقبل
أن هناك سببًا جذريًا
للمشكلة يجب معالجته ،
فأنا أعني مرة أخرى أنني سأعرف من
بدأ ماذا لأنك
في نهاية اليوم  نتحدث
عن احتلال مستمر
منذ أكثر من 60 عامًا ، أعني أن هذه مشكلة
ومشكلة كانت موجودة منذ ما يقرب من مائة
عام ، لذا
فأنت تعلم أنه يتعين علينا
قبول حقيقة أنه يجب أن تكون دولة فلسطينية مستقلة
الفلسطينيون  احترم كرامتهم حتى ننظر إلى
الصورة الكاملة بدلاً من الأعراض فقط ،
تذهب إلى الطبيب لطلب
الاهتمام وإذا قال
جيدًا انظر ، فأنت تعلم أنني سأعطيك
شيئًا لتقليل
وتهدئة اشتعال هذه المرة  لكن ارجع
إلي في كل مرة يكون هناك اندلاع آخر
لا يعمل
لمعالجة السبب الجذري للمشكلة
وهذا ما أتحدث عنه من
يخطف
ما هو موجود في استقطاب
السرد
نعم أه ناصر جودي شكرا جزيلا
لسابق  وزير الخارجية وعضو في مجلس الشيوخ
أه يتحدث إلينا يعيش من أنت لست
رجلاً صحيحًا
فقط تأكد من أنك بخير ،
أتمنى
لك أمسية سعيدة ، شكرًا لانضمامك
إلينا.